I'll say that starlett is one of my
favorite films for this year by
incredibly beautiful thank you and what
I love is that it's incredibly rich in
humanity and all the characters are
flawed and they're tragic but you still
have the thighs with them do you think
the mainstream can handle something so
emotional and deep disturbing you know I
would think the mainstream can handle
the these I would say yeah I would see
no problem with them handling that part
of it the emotion and the you know the
character development if anything it's
just you know it's it has that hardcore
scene in it so that makes it difficult
for the mainstream but I would think in
terms of the actual you know the a story
the relationship and everything like
that my hope is that it hits with the
mainstream because well you know I want
people to connect with the film and
identify with the characters and become
connected with Jane and Sadie and
invested in their relationship so yeah I
don't see why not
I mean you know the mainstream is
getting plenty of that in in
great films these days and also
wonderful you know cable when our dramas
and so yeah I think so
well starlets theme focuses really on
finding the surrogate family out the
world what's attractive about that to
you
you know it's it was it was just about I
think everybody everybody is always
looking to even if they have a strong
family unit there's always you know
there people want to connect with other
people on people and there's always a
longing for to find the connection with
other people and that's just really
something that I wanted to explore you
know maybe maybe you know being a
filmmaker you're often isolated and
you're really you're in you're on your
own little island I spent the last year
in an editing room with my dog and
that's literally I have no connect so
maybe it was my way of wanting to live
vicariously through the movie I don't
know yeah well we spoke with Chris
briefly your co-writer in a waiting room
and he said you know if he's so grateful
to be a part of this project especially
because right now such a
time to get films or really anything off
the ground how many times do they movie
fall apart
Oh fall apart well there's always you
know with these sort of movies you're
every day you're keeping it together
you're trying to keep the train moving
forward and trying you know so we but
we've been very lucky with this film we
it was a very fast pre-production the
the scripts really got everybody very
excited right off the bat in terms of
that's how we found injury Hemingway
it was because her manager really liked
the script gave it to her and she
connected with the producers came on
board very quickly so it was it was
we've been lucky but of course dealing
with a film of this budget it's you're
constantly every day just looking for
ways of just keeping everything going
because without that extra dollar it's
things could shut down at any moment so
I don't know if we ever had a full
shutdown or
I think that happened reckless I don't
know
cannabis is smooth as you
install Fountain Place direct so with
two male writers yourself in question
how are you able to come up with such
believable female needs I mean both
characters all of the characters were so
rich especially the two weeks I mean we
just really felt that they were actually
yeah I you know I don't I know how to
actually add that people have said that
about the film before and also my other
films because really the only time that
I've actually attempted to write about
my own personal experience or my what
how I grew up was with my first film and
then I was done with that and I didn't
want to deal with that anymore but it
was just I think it's a I think proper I
think that if you approach characters in
a way you just be every let me start
over
I think that people are very much if you
put yourself into those characters you
know if you people have the same dreams
and aspirations and and I think that
finding I think it's very easy to
humanize characters as long as you see
them as human I yeah we didn't set out
saying we're gonna write for women we
set out saying we're gonna write for
real people and as our you spent how
much time in bed
oh it's you know probably about six
months of editing or four to six months
of editing but of course then there's
all of that once you deliver once you
show everybody your final cut
then you come you have to get the proper
sound mix and the proper color
correction and and all of those little
things that with a budget you could
complete in a week or two and without a
budget you're stretched over the course
of months so I would say you know we
shot last August and now it's October
and so it's been a year and two months
of sort of seeing the post production
out and the distribution so working
every day I don't think we've had a day
off really literally and what made you
so hungry to hunker down like that was
at a festival deadline yeah I mean I
think that post-production can go on
forever you can keep cutting your film
again and again and again and again so
my goal was just to get a to get a cut
within a few months that we could start
showing people and I think we were
working on almost like you cut a minute
today is that right that sounds right
you
me and him we're in the room a lot he
had plowed through without becoming it
easier an error and you know you kind of
oh yeah well then you start showing more
people that you know crew friend right
job those are your test audiences right
at home right and we actually had
consultants in the adult film world to
come in and watch early cuts of the film
and tell us what they thought but you
know it's you're cutting about forty
seconds a day at best I remember now
it's forty seconds so if you think about
it you know it's a hundred minute film
that's that's more than a hundred a is
easy you shot a lot of raw footage the
fact that you did it again so fast yet
all of that raw to me is America magic
isn't right scale because well so many
different shades to choose from the
problem yeah in the end I'm happy I
edited the film we didn't have the
budget to bring an editor on but I've
edited my other stuff and now I'm really
locked into I think I'll always be
editing my stuff because I see it as so
much there was so much we made so many
creative decisions in post-production
you know how you've seen it how we have
many revelations throughout the movie
and jarring moments of you know
revealing something about a character
and whether it's Sadie or Jane or even
the dog whether it is male or female you
know we have all these or then that
actually worked its way into the style
and into the cutting so I'm glad that I
actually had
actually doing the hands-on and I what
we figured that out I don't know if that
would have come across if somebody else
was editing the film so it was part of
like for me the editing process was 50%
of directing